[Music]
I never expected to be an activist but I
was raised in a family with really
strong values I was born in the mid 50's
my parents were involved in the civil
rights movement and I grew up in a
family that believed that everyone
should have an equal opportunity and I
was also raised in a family where they
believed that we all had a
responsibility to be good citizens to be
engaged and the real question in my life
was when would my opportunity come up it
wasn't like I was looking for it it was
more that there never see be anything
going on in which I could be a useful
voice so when I began my career all of
that went into the back of my mind but I
still had a really strong value system
and I noticed beginning in 2007 that the
values of Silicon Valley were changing
the Silicon Valley was moving away from
the value system of Steve Jobs and
empowering users to starting to view the
people who used the products as a source
of economic value not a beneficiary of
it and I had to pass on a series of
companies that I knew were gonna be
successful
it started with Zynga and then Spotify
and then uber all of which I could have
been investing in practically at the
beginning I don't want to be critical of
those companies specifically but for me
my value system said I want to be
involved in companies that who know
where our values are aligned and they
they were comfortable exploiting certain
populations and I just didn't feel good
about that and that's what caused me to
think that maybe I couldn't be an
investor anymore I couldn't manage other
people's money if I wasn't willing to
invest in the best that Silicon Valley
had to offer so that's the backdrop for
2016 when I start to notice things going
wrong on Facebook the thing is that I
was convinced that Facebook was
different
when Mark started the company he
insisted on authenticated identity right
everybody had to have an email account
from a school and with that you've got
rid of trolls because people couldn't be
mean and hide behind anonymity they had
to have they had to be willing to take
whatever the social blowback was if they
didn't behave well and I thought that
was the Holy Grail and it never occurred
to me that Facebook would move away from
that but that's what they did and so in
2016 you know when I started to see
things going wrong I eventually said you
know I can't sit back and watch this I
was retired the easy thing to do would
have been to just sit there and say this
is not my problem I'll leave it to young
people who have an economic stick but
for whatever reason my value system
kicked in said this is my moment there's
something really wrong here I need to
reach out to my friends I thought mark
and Sheryl were the victims I didn't
think that they were the cause of any of
this and I wanted initially to protect
them the hard part came when I
discovered no they weren't interested in
fixing the problem they wanted to treat
as a public relations problem now I'm
faced with a quandary this is a company
I've been involved in not from the very
beginning but from year 2 or year 3 I
guess they were two years old when I
first met them and if I was gonna push
back in public I was gonna have to walk
away from what was I think probably the
most successful investment I'd made in
an incredibly successful career and it
didn't take long to make that decision I
realized that there was a real risk that
Facebook had been used to affect the
outcome of the 2016 election it was
almost certainly a factor in the brexit
referendum in the United Kingdom and who
knew what else
I mean we've since discovered you know
it was a factor in you know genocide in
Myanmar and in hate speech related
killings in Sri Lanka
election interference in many countries
in Europe maybe even turning over an
election Brazil with whatsapp and but I
didn't know that that what I knew was I
had seen something I couldn't live with
and I'd profited from this thing and I
couldn't very well sit back and do
nothing
given I'd been involved I profited and I
saw something I knew wasn't right it was
one of those moments where you have to
do you have to make a choice if I was
gonna stand up on this issue what issue
was I gonna stand up on right I mean
this was where my value system comes
into play is it just talk or am I gonna
walk the walk
now what did it mean most of the people
that I've been most closely associated
with professionally are not comfortable
with me anymore
some of them say really awful things
about me much of it completely not true
and I'm okay with that I'm okay with
that because I believe what I'm doing is
right and I believe that if Mark and
she'll get a good night's sleep
if illyrians sir you get a good night's
sleep they'll wake up and realize
they'll have an epiphany that they've
been successful beyond their wildest
dreams and the time has come to be the
hero in their own story that the next
billion dollars isn't worth anything to
them that they can do more good in you
know in a year by reforming their
companies they can ever do with a
foundation
you